absolution is the fifth game in the
Hitman series which started in 2000 and
its pin it's been a while now since we
released the game and we basically built
an entire new technology for this game
and also picked apart every single
mechanic of the old games and put them
back together again the eight-man series
is notorious for being very hardcore and
difficult to play this is something we
regret making it far more forgiving for
the regular players there's still a lot
of content for the hardcore people and
they this more replayability in this
game than any of the other games
actually so you can say we've had this
very this very large focus for this game
that it needs to be accessible but at
the same time it needs to be ultra
hardcore for for all our fans one of the
first things we start with is finding
out how many different ways can you play
this true and and how how why do we make
the game play it's it's all up to the
player if they want to play it stealthy
or if you want to play action if they
want to use disguises or not we use a
guilty one problem that we've felt we
had with the old games was that unless
you're an expert player you basically
look like a rubbish hitman playing the
games very kind of clunky and always
like ending up in a firefight so we
focused a lot of empowering the player
that being a great hitman isn't the
problem its kind of solving the
situations in whatever way you want and
containing the situations unless you
want a huge fight of course then
that's up to the player it's on ps3 xbox
360 and PC and it's coming out in 2012